and speaking of predicting the way that
things are gonna play out Donald Trump's
trade Wars he escalated them earlier
this week when he announced that he was
putting a 10% tariff on at least 200
billion dollars worth of new goods
coming from China to the United States
almost immediately after that he a China
announced that they would respond
accordingly and put in these retaliatory
tariffs but 20 billion two hundred
billion dollars excuse me
ten percent tariff on these so Donald
Trump's Commerce Secretary Wilbur Ross
decides that he's gonna make everybody
calm he's gonna try to help everybody
understand that yeah this is a lot of a
lot of tariffs we have twenty billion
dollars total ten percent of two hundred
billion but really it's not that big of
a deal so Wilbur Ross goes on television
and tells us this here it is mr.
secretary average American family making
$50,000 a year let's say how much do you
expect these tariffs will impact them
meaning have you done the math so that
so you know what a family would it would
an average family in America will pay
once these tariffs go into effect well
you can do the numbers this way if you
have a 10% tariff on another 200 billion
that's 20 billion a year that's a tiny
tiny tiny fraction of 1% total inflation
in the US because it's spread over
thousands and thousands of products
nobody's gonna actually notice it at the
end of the day nobody's gonna notice it
right I mean 20 billion dollars extra
that that we're gonna end up paying each
year but we're not gonna notice it I
mean of course the billionaire Wilbur
Ross wouldn't expect us to notice price
increases and in case you're wondering
these are goods they're refrigerators
air conditioners toys you know things
that actually average American citizens
by it's not like they're putting this
massive tax on yachts and marble for
countertops in mansions
these are things that we purchased
things that we need to have furthermore
Wilbur Ross the billionaire doesn't
quite seem to understand how the economy
works because it's not a total of ten
percent like this item gets taxed at
point zero five percent and it adds up
to 10 percent eventually what is he
talking about but that's what he told us
there he said yeah it's ten percent
total when you add everything up no it
would be a ten percent roughly increase
on the individual items and think about
this you're a middle-class family right
maybe not even quite middle-class yet
you're pulling in thirty forty thousand
dollars a year as a family household
maybe a four two kids married couple
forty thousand dollars a year you need
to go buy a new refrigerator because
yours just quit usually eight nine
hundred dollars low-end model right
suddenly that eight hundred dollars goes
up to nine hundred dollars when you're
already on a very limited fixed income
that increase of one hundred dollars
that matters that's a doctor's visit
that is a prescription refilled here in
the United States so suddenly now
families have to choose do we do we get
the new refrigerator and go without a
prescription this month what do we do
and again 100% of this lies at the feet
of Donald Trump and his idiotic
billionaire advisors who keep telling
him that no nobody's gonna notice these
dramatic price increases because we
don't notice them and we're billionaires
it makes absolutely no sense but that's
this administration unfair and cousins
and for David Pakman we'll be right back
one of today's sponsors is Skillshare
which is an amazing online learning
community that offers thousands of high
quality classes on almost any topic the
first 500 people will click the link
under this video we'll get to entire
months of totally free access to every
single class offered by Skillshare
they've got classes on everything design
video editing photography
business technology cooking meditation
even classes on how to become a more
productive person I know you'll be able
to find something on Skillshare that
fascinates you or will help you with
something in your everyday life classes
are taught by real people who care about
what they're teaching I just took a
really great class on more advanced
video editing techniques the david
pakman show is giving you two months of
free access to every class they offer
when you click the link under this video
I mean really just think about
everything that you'll have at your
fingertips for two whole months totally
free that's hard to beat and after that
if you like it you can keep having
access to every class on Skillshare for
less than ten bucks a month it's one of
the most affordable learning platforms
out there just click the link under this
video to redeem your to three months of
Skillshare but hurry because it's only
available to the first 500 people who
sign up